(audience clapping)
I am so excited
to see how Catherine's makeup turned out.
Let's see Catherine before
in all her all or nothing glory looks.
All right.
And let's see Catherine now, come on out.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
(Catherine laughing)
Oh my god.
I'm sorry but I can't even help it, you're so hot.
(audience laughs)
Oh my god.
Why thank you.
You really wow that is the power of beauty,
but the most important thing is how do you feel?
I feel great.
This look is fantastic, the makeup,
the face oil is so lightweight it feels like nothing.
The lip balm is very hydrating, the mascara.
I actually can't wait to try the mascara myself, that's my.
(audience cheering)
Come.
Come sit down.
(Catherine laughs)
Come sit down in my chair.
Okay.
I mean speaking to the products,
tell us about what you did.
Well also speaking to the fact that it's green,
but it also looks beautiful.
Catherine your skin is glowing, you look amazing.
So we just paired--
Thank you.
Back her look.
We went with something casual
she could wear it all the time, do it herself.
I just, and then we sent her to the salon
and we put some highlights in her and warmed it up a bit
and gave her--
The highlights
are really good because they're not too juxtaposing.
When I see a highlight that isn't the right tint or tone
I get so mad.
Oh I know.
(audience laughs)
Me too.
I'm like why did you do that to that person?
You just turned them into tiger zebra.
(everyone laughing)
And I like that they don't start at the root,
they kind of just fade out
and they get lighter towards the bottom.
(audience clapping)
I like that.
And.
Do you.
Feel empowered?
'Cause baby man (Jenna laughs) you look so beautiful.
I have to say,
I'm always in scrubs, (audience clapping) or running,
(Jenna laughs) or then I'm in an evening gown.
So this I feel like a business woman like I'm ready to go,
like I'm ready--
You are!
To take on the world.
Well your husband and brother are here,
is that true?
Yes.
Wait.
(audience clapping)
(Catherine laughing)
May I ask your husband and brother
how you guys feel about this look
and what you think of your extraordinary wife and sister?
Drew I agree with you, she looks hot,
she looks really hot.
(everyone laughing)
(audience clapping)
She always looks beautiful,
but yeah she fantastic, and I'm so proud of her.
And she went through a lot these past couple of years
and she deserves this, she does, she does.
(audience clapping)
Oh thank you.
Thank you love.
All right.
And she looks like a totally different person to me.
(audience laughs) I usually only see her at work.
(Catherine laughs) So I usually only see her
in that non makeup look.
And yeah it looks amazing.
WelL I'm so glad you gentlemen approve,
(audience cheering) that's so wonderful.
And Catherine we're gonna give a bundle of the makeup
Green Edition to you.
(Catherine cheers)
And boy did everybody come on a good day
because we are giving everyone in the audience,
you are going home with a Maybelline Green Edition
makeup and 100 dollar
gift card (everyone clapping) to Walmart.
(audience cheering) So.
That is your Maybelline Green makeup.
You guys are all getting stuff,
and 100 dollar gift certificate to Walmart.
So chocolate, makeup, gift cards,
that's the--
Chocolate.
(audience clapping)
I like this.
And to learn what Green Edition means,
please visit Maybelline dot com back slash Green Edition.
They are leading the charge, may we all follow.
This gives me so much hope
and I'm so grateful to work with Maybelline.
(audience clapping) So thank you.
And thank you Jenna and Catherine!
(upbeat music)